welcome everyone uh my name is Sean
Baker and I'm the CSO and founder of
Alek and today I'm going to be talking
to you about the impact of the Thousand
genome on medicine so before I get into
it I just want to remind everyone that
uh in the leand corner there's a little
Q&A button so as I give the talk if you
have any questions or comments please
open that up and uh just ask anything
you like and at the end I'd be happy to
try to answer it okay
so with that let's go ahead and get
started um but before I actually get
into the Thousand genome and what it
means for you I need to kind of explain
who Alek is so we're this sequencing
Marketplace what we do is we offer a
free resource that matches researchers
with sequencing providers so if someone
needs to do some sequencing they don't
know where to get it from we help them
find the right providers now even though
we do this we actually don't offer any
sequencing ourselves we don't own any of
the sequencers so that means we're able
to maintain um a neutral stance we don't
have a vested interest in any one of the
Technologies so without any over bias we
can guide people to the right thing
right technology the right provider for
their particular research
project doing this has really given us a
unique perspective on this Market
because our users trust us with this uh
neutral stance they let us know what
their budgets are we know what kind of
projects they're running what kind of
species they're running uh what
technology platforms they want um we
also see exactly how much their projects
cost so this G gives us a really
interesting and unique view into the
market and it's part of that that I'm
going to share with you
today so the big news this year of
course is that the Thousand genome is
finally
here sort of there's actually some some
caveats I'm going to walk you through
those caveats so what's caused all this
this is from the um announcement earlier
this year from alumina uh with the
launch of their High seek X10 this is
their latest instrument their their
largest and with the highest output so
what exactly is this instrument and how
is it getting us to the $1,000 vome so
it's based on their um at least Loosely
based on their High seek 2500 their
current Flagship product but it has a
greater output it's actually able to
generate 600 gigabases of data per day
and over a three-day run that means it
can output 1.8 terab bases that's uh .8
trillion bases incredible amount of
output that's actually enough data that
that single instrument can generate uh
five human whole genome sequences per
day uh and then of course if you run it
all year that means that one instrument
can generate over 1,800 genom per year
so how does it do this what are the
major advancements um two things one is
uh a new flow cell this is a pattern
flow cell it allows the instrument to
Peck in more data data per
run uh and then the other thing is
improved Optics and what these Optics do
is allow that run to be shorter so
between these two they're really able to
to jack up the output uh per day per run
so that's giving you all that data and
then of course they've reduce the price
uh to
match so this sounds really great uh new
instrument lots of outputs uh better
than anything that's out there what's
the catch what's going on here so so the
Advent of nextg sequencing and as its
gain popularity has really broadened out
its usage uh people are basically using
it for anything that has DNA anything
has DNA it's being sequenced just uh the
the amount of applications the amount of
species that are being looked at is just
tremendous and we see everything on all
SE sequencing Marketplace the high seek
X10 however is only able to look at one
species and that's human
not only that it's only able to look at
humans using one application and that's
whole genome sequencing so that means
you obviously can't look at other
species can't look at cattle can't look
at plants only humans but also you can't
look at other applications you can't use
exome sequencing you can't use it to
look at say for example the methylome or
the transcriptome just that one
application and one
species but it is able to deliver the
Thousand gen so I'm going to go ahead
and walk you through exactly how that
happens uh what it's able to do so the
first thing is if you want this thousand
genome you've got to buy an instrument
and this instrument the x10 is the most
expensive instrument on the market at $1
million so it's already pretty pricey
but alumina throws another Wrinkle in
there you're not allowed to buy just one
you actually have to buy 10 of them at a
time at least so that means you have a
minimum capital outlay of $10 million
it's already a pretty big barrier for
most
people so
how does the actual thousand genome
break down where what is that money
covering about $800 of that is for the
actual sequencing reagents generating
the sequence 135 is for the instrument
amortization basically paying off that
instrument one genome at a time and the
remaining $65 covers kind of everything
else so that means the library prep both
reagents and the labor for it and then
basic data analysis but there are some
things that doesn't cover um more
specialized
analysis uh the cost of energy the
storage of the data uh overhead the
building that it's in all those kind of
things which are kind of hard to
calculate uh globally but if you have
your own building if someone else is
paying the electricity and you buy this
instrument you can get the genome for
$1,000 so let's walk through what that
would actually mean if you're operating
this
machine so I mentioned before that it's
able to generate enough data for five
goms a day so that means every day that
you're operating it it's going to cost
you5 $5,000 to run and of course if you
run it for a whole year like you should
it's going to cost you $1.8 million to
run generating about 1,800
genomes but if you remember I said
you're not allowed to buy just one
instrument you have to buy 10 of them so
operating all 10 instruments for a year
is actually going to cost you $18
million generating 18,000 genomes but
one more Wrinkle In order to get that uh
instrument price down to $135 per sample
aluminous calculated that you actually
have to run this instrument for four
years so to get that1 thousand genome
you're actually going to have to spend
$72
million that's a pretty big capital
outlay and um but some people have been
willing to do it uh they've actually had
13 customers Pony up that money so far
if you're not one of them if you don't
have the $72 million to spend but you
still want to get that inexpensive vium
all is not lost that's one of the
reasons we created uh the sequencing
Marketplace you can go to alek.com
genome and we'll help you get set up
we'll we'll help you describe your
project and get you Ma with one of the
providers who actually owns one of the
x10
instruments okay enough about us so with
the Advent of this X10 and bringing the
cost of whole genome sequencing down so
far it's really um sparked A Renewed
interest in the debate between whole
genome sequencing versus xome sequencing
so I just kind of want to walk through
that briefly to tell you uh what the
differences are and why you might choose
one over the other so here we're just
looking at a representation of the human
genome um we have obviously all the the
chromosomes out here if we zoom in uh
we're looking at a gene and in this Gene
we have the exons which are the protein
coating portions and then the introns
which are non-coated and then of course
if you zoom in even more you'll get the
individual
bases so for whole genome sequencing of
course as the name implies it attempts
to sequence the entire genum that's why
I've highlighted all of these
chromosomes every region of them in
practice it doesn't reach 100% there are
some regions which are just technically
challenging High GC content a lot of
repeats things like the tiir and centr
mirors they're pretty hard to cover but
in general uh the application covers
around 95 to maybe 98% of the genome for
each gene um it tries to cover the
entire Gene so again both the exons and
the introns and of course um every
single individual
base Exon sequencing in contrast is much
more focused so it's still looking at
the entire genome but instead it's just
focing focusing on individual genes also
within those genes it's really just
focusing on the Exxon so that protein
coding region and of course within the
Exxon it's trying to get every single
base so we do see that it's still jing a
lot of data just not as much in general
depending on the product that you use to
do the enrichment it's somewhere between
40 to maybe 60 megabases representing
1.3 up to maybe around 2% of the genome
and that would be compared again to 95
to 98% of the
genome so given these two uh
applications and the strengths and
weaknesses which one's better it really
depends on what you're going for so
let's just kind of walk through some of
the characteristics of these first you
have price that's where the exom
sequencing has traditionally been the
leader um up until recently hom
sequencing was anywhere from five to 10
times more expensive as the Exon so
people had limited budgets or who wanted
to sequence more samples tended to use
that XOM sequencing with Advent of the
x10 uh that difference in price is
really diminished it's closer to two
times more expensive of whole GM
sequencing now so not nearly the price
difference that it's been in the past in
terms of coverage full genome sequencing
obviously has exone beat like I said it
covers up to 98% of the genome whereas
the exone maxes out at around 2% so if
you want to look at non-coding regions
whole genome sequencing is definitely
the way to go another way that whole
genome sequencing is actually Superior
is maybe a slightly surprising way and
that's in the
uniformity due to the way that uh exone
pull down occurs it actually uh leads to
some nonuniform sequencing some are
basically easier to enrich than others
and so you get some sequences that you
just get a lot of data for and other
regions that you get much less data for
so overall you actually have to run xomm
sequencing at a higher depth say around
100x versus more typical for whole
genome sequencing of 30X and that's
really just to make sure that you have
minimum coverage in all the regions that
you're interested
in another area that exome actually
shines however compared to whole genome
is on the analysis side and that's just
because you're looking at less data when
you're only analyzing 2% of the genome
and that 2% is actually the portion that
is um much better understood it's just
easier analysis so some people who feel
they don't have uh the time or the money
or the expertise to look at non-coding
regions we'll just concentrate on the
exone now some proponents of whole
genome sequencing kind of agree with
that but they still want the better
uniformity and the greater coverage of
whole GM sequencing so they sequence
everything but then they might restrict
their analysis just to the protein
coding portions of the exone so they
generate more data than they need uh but
then keep the analysis simple they just
look at a restricted
portion okay so this is all really
interesting um lots of great
developments the question then is what
if anything is this doing for the clinic
and in order to understand that it's
important to to look at the
characteristics of what researchers want
versus what clinicians want so
researchers traditionally have they just
wanted increased output they've got
large projects and they just want to
generate more and more data and that's
what they've really been pushing the the
sequencing vendors to do of course they
also want to have lower cost uh
especially lower cost per base so that
each genly sequence cost less and less
money and that's been a huge driver of
this Market over the past five 10
years they're also uh willing to
tolerate and in some cases demanding of
Rapid updates so once they buy the
instrument they know that's not the end
of the equation they know that company's
going to keep developing new instruments
keep working to improve things and they
want those improvements to show up in
their instruments that they've already
had installed so you'll often see uh
updates come out in the field um
sometimes twice a year sometimes even
once a quarter or once a month these
updates are sometimes about Hardware
sometimes about software but the whole
point is to increase that output and
increase uh or rather continue to lower
the cost for them clinicians however
have a different set of needs what they
really want above everything else is
simple ease of use they really just want
to be able to push a button and get an
answer out they generally don't care too
much about the technology and they just
aren't as sensitive to these other
things that researchers are they also
really need a quick turnaround time so
our researchers might be willing to wait
uh weeks or even months for their large
project and then analyze it for months
and even years after that a clinician is
generally working with a patient sample
and something to which they didn't
answer right away U more like days or
even hours because it's directly going
to lead to some sort of uh treatment
decision for that customer or that uh
patient the other thing that they really
want that's in high contrast to
researchers is they want stability they
don't want those rapid updates once they
buy a machine and they get used to it
and they see that it works they want to
make sure that what it did today is the
same thing it's going to do tomorrow or
next week next month or even next year
so they really uh value that
stability so how is this technology
being actually adopted into the clinic
so there's actually only one instrument
that is officially sanctioned for
clinical research and that's the my DX
last November it was the first
instrument to become clear by the
FDA uh this has been so successful
however that aluminum has decided to
also submit their larger instrument the
Heek 2500 with a novel assay and then
alumina's biggest customer
thermofisher is uh going to submit their
instrument
PGM for FDA clearance sometime later
this year we're still kind of waiting
for some updates on that so this is the
only official instrument that's been
cleared it it doesn't mean it's the only
instrument that's actually being used in
a clinical setting Labs that are cleia
certified uh can and have been using
other instruments um that may be
changing fda's come out with some recent
pronouncements they're going to start
looking more carefully at these ldts
laboratory design test so we'll see how
that changes in the future for right now
people are using non FDA cleared
instruments in a clinical setting as
long as a as it's a Clea approved
laboratory so what kind of tests are
actually being used right now with
patient data uh we've talked about whole
genome sequencing and exom sequencing uh
but there are also smaller tests so so
larger than a single Gene but smaller
than exone where uh people are looking
at a large number of genes so one
example is foundation uh Health they
have a test that looks at over
300 uh genes and genomic regions that
are related to cancer another similar
kind of thing is a company called invite
they have taken over 250 individual
genetic tests and combine them into a
single assay that they're selling for
$1,500 this is kind of a unique business
model for them they say to the
Physicians go ahead and look at all
these 250 test decide how many you want
to run whether it's a single test just a
handful or all um 250 the price is
actually the same still
$1500 not only that the physician can
order a single test or just a handful
look at the analysis and they don't see
what they were looking for if they do it
quickly enough they can actually go back
to the company and get them to reanalyze
the rest of those tests because they're
actually running all of them at once
when you choose just one or a handful
really what you're saying is just share
with me that amount of data so it's
pretty flexible and relatively cheap
especially comp compared to what those
uh 250 individual tests would have
cost so that that's an example those
were examples of uh more focused tests
uh but it's also being used next gen
sequencing is also being used on the
whole genome scale um primarily uh you
know for things like cancer that was one
of the first things that was adopted for
it uh to be honest this is often used as
a um
last case scenario when nothing else has
worked either when the traditional
genetic tests haven't shown something
useful or maybe when the patient isn't
responding to the traditional drugs a
physician can order a whole genome test
to look at all of the genome to see if
there's something else they might have
missed something unusual that's going on
that might indicate uh a different drug
that they wouldn't have otherwise chosen
to be honest this is It's clinical and
that it's directly treating a patient
but it's really more of a research
project once they generate all that data
the individual physician usually is not
in a position to really look at it they
need to assemble a research team around
them to quickly dig into it people who
are expert experts in genomics and in
cancer to try to figure out what's going
on a similar kind of story uh goes on
with uh rare childhood diseases same
kind of thing this is usually um a test
of Last Resort they've either looked at
other genetic tests and found nothing or
they just don't even really know what to
look for they'll sequence the child and
often sequence both the parents looking
for what's different what's gone on just
any clue that they can get uh to to
indicate a potential treatment but again
this is really more of a research
project than it is a traditional
clinical test and just that it it's uh
it's not scalable takes a lot of people
and a lot of expertise a lot of time and
and quite a bit of money to be
honest a much more broadly available
technology is is the relatively new one
of the non-invasive prenatal testing or
nip this this is an assay that if you'd
ask pretty much anyone three years ago
what's the first whole genome sequencing
assay to take off probably no one would
have chosen this but it's incredibly
popular it's uh it's attracted a lot of
commercial interest I've shown to some
of the companies here are who are
offering nip testing and if you don't
know what this is it it's basically a
replacement for
amniocentesis so when uh pregnant women
uh who are looking to see if there might
be some disease they need to worry about
in their unborn child uh like down
syndrome they would use the very
invasive process of amoc synthesis it's
not been replaced with a simple blood
draw from the from the mother basically
there's enough fetal DNA floating around
in the mother's bloodstream that they
can actually uh determine these genetic
diseases prior to birth so it's uh much
easier much safer than the traditional
methods so with the uh
the impact that nextg sequencing is
having on research and as it's moving
into the clinic it's important to ask
what's the impact on patients what
what's actually happening to the
Frontline people here and a big big
question that people are TR still trying
to answer is what exactly should these
patients be allowed to see so often um a
test will be ordered looking for a
particular
genomic uh region they have a particular
question in mind that because of the
nature of the technology it's actually
really easy to find things in other
parts of the genome that you weren't
really interested necessarily in asking
about but you might find something that
you weren't expecting to see this is
often called the
incidental so harking back to the nip
testing that we just talked about is
actually a great example so the test is
designed to look at the fetal DNA to see
if they have these these rare diseases
but the fetal DNA in in a in a Mother's
blood only represents about maybe two to
10% at the most of the DNA that's
floating around the rest is of course
the maternal DNA so even though they're
looking for the fetal DNA they're mostly
finding out information about the mother
mostly they ignore it but occasionally
they find something that's quite
dramatic either um you know a gene that
shows they're extremely susceptible to
cancer or maybe something like
Huntington's disease where they know
with 100% certainty that that Mother's
going to get it and they then are put in
a quandry you know the patient came to
us asking about their fetus but we found
out something about the mother what
should we do and they're really looking
for some guidance there acmg came out
with some recommendations last year to
try to help answer this they came up
with a list of 56 genes uh for which
they said if there are abnormal results
they should be reported to that patient
regardless of what the patient wished
now that actually was fairly
controversial and they got a lot of
feedback
uh from their users and from the general
public and so they've come back later
this year and they've modified that so
it's no longer regardless of what the
patient wishes instead what they're
saying now is when that test is
prescribed but before it's given they
should be able to opt out of any future
uh results that they actually just don't
want to hear about so it's a discussion
that goes on between the patient and the
doctor to figure out what exactly do you
want to know if we happen to find
something but this is still an evolving
thing a moving Target and uh everyone's
really just working together trying to
figure out what the best thing to do
is okay regardless of what you do a big
portion of nextg sequencing actually is
all about analyzing the data and this is
really critical for clinical aspects
it's there's a lot of things involved
but the things that are most important
are the the tertiary types of analysis
this is annotating The genome and
visualizing the data perhaps even more
important than that is actually the
reporting of the data Physicians really
want to see the uh not so much the
underlying data but what does it mean
what should they do for their patient so
this is an example of a fast Q file this
is essentially raw sequencing data this
is what it looks like we're seeing um of
course the individual bases and then
we're seeing uh essentially quality
calls how how good that data is this is
a very tiny example just showing 25
bases per run and just three individual
sequences uh if you were to run this
today this would be file basically a
text file that is a billion lines long
obviously not something that a physician
or even a researcher can easily just
look through instead what the clinicians
are really looking for is something way
down the line they want this not just to
be data but they want interpretation
they want a medical report something
that's actually specific to their
particular patient that has uh the
context of what the patient phenotype is
what the genomic anomalies are in that
patient that are probably relevant to
that phenotype and even farther they
want to know what are some recommended
courses that I should be looking at to
help this patient what are the drugs out
there what are the treatments that they
need based on all this information
that's really what they want to get to
there's a number of companies working on
this it's obviously a hot area we see
new companies coming in all the time uh
trying to come up with really slick
Solutions I would say nobody has really
dominated this yet but it's still such a
strong need that um you know it's it's
pretty clear this is going to be a hot
field for a while
while so one of the advantages of uh
running the sequencing Marketplace is we
get to keep a really close eye on the
future Trends one of the things that a
lot of people have been talking about is
nanoport sequencing this is actually
using um uh nanopores to measure the DNA
as they pass through the holes bases
looking at how the DNA molecules disturb
the electri electrical conductance um
it's still early days there is a company
Oxford nanapur who has an instrument out
in Early Access and I'm showing it here
it's called the minion it is a uh
essentially a handheld little machine
and it plugs in straight to your
computer with a USB so you just pop in
some DNA plug it into your computer and
it starts generating sequence it's still
early it's unclear how good it really is
but it is producing really long reads
which is kind of a new thing in this
field uh unlike that million dooll high-
seek X that uh some people are buying
get a thousand genome this instrument is
probably going to cost more like a$
thousand dollar it obviously won't
generate nearly as much DNA but it's a
really low Capital outlay so people are
pretty excited about
it another area uh that we see becoming
more and more important and people we
see people asking for this all the time
on the sequencing Marketplace is single
cell sequencing so for a typical uh
sample prep people are often looking at
you know uh tens of thousands to
hundreds of thousands of cells all
together and so they they they combine
all that DNA together and sequence it so
obviously the sequencing they're doing
is generating an average across all
those cells uh for many applications
that's not a problem at all so if you're
just looking at a standard genome uh
with very rare exceptions it really
doesn't uh change from cell to cell in
your body so it doesn't matter if you're
looking at an average but there are some
applications where it could be
critically important so for example in
uh tumor tissues uh that's going to be a
mixture of a lot lot of different cell
types uh both tumor and normal and even
within the
tumor uh you'll have different states of
of mutation in the different cells so if
you could it would actually be better to
look at individual cells uh look at
their genomes one at a time and then
analyze them in aggregate but being able
to split them all out so I'm just
showing you here an instrument called
the C1 from a company that's fluidy uh
they're kind of the Forefront of the
commercial uh instruments looking at
single cells
the other thing that we're seeing that's
of uh extreme interest in people is
cellfree DNA sequencing so the nip
testing I talked about before that was
an example but another example that's um
not as welld developed but there's an
incredible amount of interest in would
be self-re DNA sequencing for cancer
obviously if you could
detect uh DNA from cancer cells as
they're just floating around the
bloodstream uh well before you would see
a tumor that's going to lead to some
really powerful really early diagnostic
so we have a lot of people who are
working on
that so uh just a reminder uh everything
I've been talking about today has been
DNA sequencing but that's really just
the tip of the iceberg so um obviously
there's a lot more going on there's a
lot of regulation of the genome
methylation acetalation things like that
there's also the RNA so uh mrnas that
code for proteins uh small RNA other
non-coding rnas all of the stuff is of
tremendous interest in the research
field and it's very likely to make its
way uh into the clinic as well it's just
not uh not there quite as quickly as the
DNA side but rest assured it will
continue to become more more important
in the
future so with that I'll go ahead and
stop I want to thank you all for
attending today um as I mentioned before
over in the left hand corner we have a
little Q&A box and I see some people
have uh put some questions in there and
that's great great I'm going to try to
answer some of those right now uh so if
you have some questions right now please
go ahead and type them in if uh for some
reason you don't think of the question
today or you just want to get some more
information please check out our website
uh all seek.com you can also email me
directly at seanad alek.com I'd be happy
to help you out so with that let's go
ahead and I'm going to open up the Q&A
box and and see um what we have
um so we have a question about uh
coverage um what would be the
recommended coverage to find both germal
mutations and sematic mutations um you
know that that's a great question we we
get questions about coverage all the
time you know how much sequencing do I
need um obviously it affects cost of the
project um and it really depends on what
you're looking at so if you've got a
pure sample and you're doing something
like like whole genome
sequencing that uh has pretty uniform
coverage the the typical answers is
around 30X coverage uh sometimes up to
40x or 50x so you're talking about 100
gigabases for a human
genome um however samples aren't always
pure and people aren't always using
assays that have uniform coverage so if
you're doing something like exom
sequencing um it's typical that they
will go to a higher coverage more like
100x and again that's really just to
ensure that all areas that you're
targeting have at least about a 10x
coverage because that's really what you
need in order to um be able to make sure
you can tell the difference between a
heterozygous mutation and homozygous
mutation now the other area is when you
don't have a homogeneous sample you've
got say that that tumor tissue uh that
might be a mixture of a bunch of
different cell types and you can't do
single cell sequencing yet um in that
case you know we've seen people go as
high as a THX using XOM sequencing and
that's because not only do they want the
higher coverage to make sure they get
that uniformity but also if they're only
looking at say one cell of Interest out
of 10 10% of the cells in that tissue
are really what they want to look at you
need to have higher
coverage
um okay this is great someone someone
else is asking about whether there any
indications that um alumina is going to
extend the capabilities of that high X10
as I mentioned it's only useful for um
humans and only used for whole genome
sequencing you know in both cases those
restrictions are um purely marketing
decisions there's really nothing
technical that would prevent it um when
you buy the machine you sign a contract
saying that you won't do otherwise and
alumina keeps I think pretty close uh uh
look at that um but like I said there's
nothing technical to prevent it so it's
very likely in the future at some point
that they will open it up uh probably
first to exom sequencing for humans is
my guess yes and then after that you
know maybe to other things like
methylation and transcripton work um the
reason they've done that really is for
marketing they they they already
dominate the market they own probably
about 80% of the next gen sequency
market and rather than collapse that
with just reducing the prices what they
wanted to do was expand the market so
they created this machine and created
really low pricing so that people could
start doing projects that involve not
just hundreds of cells uh hundreds of
samples
but uh tens of thousands to hundreds of
thousands of samples this is when you're
sequencing entire populations and it's
really uh until that market seems to
really be well established they they'll
probably uh maintain those restrictions
that that's my guess um another question
that we have is is talking about the
actual price of a$ thousand gome you
know it's called $1,000 G that's kind of
a shorthand but as I mentioned you
actually don't get that price unless you
have 72 million to spend over four years
um more typical uh for people is to go
through a provider to get that and there
the price is going to be uh obviously
more than $ thousand dollar because
there's more things that go into that
there's some labor and some overhead and
some profit that has to be made um in
general it's really going to depend on
if you want anything unusual you know
the more plain vanilla if you're just
using a blood sample and you don't need
any um really special data analysis uh
and you have very high volumes uh very
high volumes say thousand samples or
more you can start getting that price
down to somewhere say between $1,500 and
$1600 if you have a much smaller um uh
volume of samples you're working with
Say closer to 10 it's going to be more
expensive still it's probably going to
be some somewhere in the $2,000 range so
it's still a a pretty low
price okay with that I think um um looks
like we've answered most of the
questions so what I'd like to do is just
go ahead and thank everyone for
participating today and thank everyone
who ask any questions and then of course
if you have any other questions you
think of anything else please feel free
to check out our website and uh or email
me directly be happy to answer them best
I could again thanks to everyone for
joining appreciate
it